yes you know I used to live here
won't you come in it's the least I can
do is it like you remember cleaner well
you feel free to look around well I get
the water boiling your hair is winter
fire
[Music]
there you go
awesome music I do apologize
it gets so very hot here this time of
year it's fine
what do you feel like you could just
about die but you know what they say
about dairy hmm no one who dies here
ever really dies
but tell me how is it being back in
Derry it's got a strange strange oh my I
had some cookies in the oven before you
came Steve right there I shouldn't
impose I'm gonna no I insist
we photos are lovely miss Kirsch are
these your family my father came to this
country with $14 in his pocket
what did he do mrs. Kirsch my father
joined the circus
I was always daddy's little girl what
about you are you still his little girl
Beverly are you
[Music]
smear the losers Club is officially
begun
[Music]
I was gonna do this but you have to
stick together
[Music]
you